[Applause]
uh thank you mr speaker can i
congratulate the prime minister on her
appointment
[Music]
when when she said when she said in her
leadership campaign that she was against
windfall taxes
did she mean it yeah
well i thank the uh right honourable
gentleman for his welcome i hope that we
will be able to work together
particularly on areas we agree on
and i know that we have had strong
support from the opposition in opposing
vladimir putin's appalling war in
ukraine and i want us to continue to
stand up to that appalling russian
aggression that has led to the energy
crisis we face now
i am against a windfall tax i believe it
is the wrong thing to be
me to be putting
companies off investing in the united
kingdom just when we need to be growing
the economy
mr speaker uh thank you for the answer i
ask because the treasury estimates are
that the energy producers will make 170
billion pounds in excess profits over
the next two years
the prime minister knows she's no choice
but to back an energy price freeze
but it won't be cheap and the real
choice
the political choice is
who is going to pay
is she really telling us that she's
going to leave these vast excess profits
on the table
and make working people foot the bill
for decades to come
well i understand that people across our
country
are struggling with the cost of living
and they're struggling with their energy
bills and that is why i as prime
minister
will take immediate action to help
people with the cost of their energy
bills and i will be making an
announcement
to this house on that tomorrow
and giving people certainty to make sure
that they are able to get through this
winter
and be able to have the energy supplies
and be able to afford it but we can't
just deal with today's problem we can't
just put a sticking plaster on it what
we need to do is increase our energy
supplies long term and that is why we
will open up more supply in the north
sea which the honorable gentleman has
opposed that is why we will build more
nuclear power stations which the labour
party didn't do when they were in office
and that is why we will get on with
delivering the supply as well as helping
people through the winter
well i look forward to tomorrow's
statement but the money's got to come
from somewhere
and she she knows that every single
pound in excess profits she chooses not
to tax is an extra pound on borrowing
that working people will be forced to
pay back for decades to come
more borrowing than is needed that's the
true cost of her choice to protect oil
and gas profits isn't it
mr speaker the reality is that this
country will not be able to tax its way
to growth
the way the way we will grow our economy
is by attracting investment keeping
taxes low delivering the reforms to
build projects quicker that is the way
that we will create jobs and
opportunities across our country
so mr speaker her first act as prime
minister is to borrow more than is
needed because she won't touch excess
oil and gas profits
on that topic how much would her planned
corporation tax cut hand out to
companies
the right honourable gentleman is
looking at this in the wrong way
the last time
the last time
we cut corporation tax
we attracted more revenue
into the exchequer because more
companies wanted to base themselves in
britain more countries wanted to
invest more companies wanted to invest
in our country
and if taxes are put up
and raised to the same level as france
which is what the current proposal is
and which i will change as prime
minister
that will put off investors it'll put
off
those companies investing our economy
and ultimately that will mean fewer jobs
less growth and less opportunities
across our country
[Applause]
mr speaker it's extraordinary that not
only is the prime minister refusing to
extend the windfall tax she's also
choosing to have the water companies
polluting our beaches a tax cut
[Music]
she's choosing
[Applause]
she's choosing to hand the banks a tax
cut add it all together
and companies that are already doing
well are getting a 17 billion pound tax
cut
while working people pay for the cost of
living crisis
stroke victims wait an hour for an
ambulance and criminals walk the streets
with impunity
families and public services need every
penny they can get
how on earth does she think
that now is the right time to protect
shells profits and give amazon a tax
break
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm on the side of people who work hard
and do the right thing
that
is will reverse the national insurance
increase and that is why we will keep
corporation tax low because ultimately
we want investment right across our
country we want new jobs and new
opportunities and that is what i will
deliver as prime minister
[Applause]
mr speaker the prime minister claims to
be breaking orthodoxy but the reality is
she's reheating george osborne's failed
corporation tax plan
protecting oil and gas profits and
forcing working people to pay the bill
she's the fourth tory prime minister in
six years the face at the top may change
but the story remains the same
there is nothing new about the tory
fantasy of trickle-down economics
nothing new about this tory prime
minister who nodded through every single
decision that got us into this mess and
now says how terrible it is
and can't she see
there's nothing new about a tory prime
minister who when asked
who pays
says it's you
the working people of britain
well there's nothing new about a labour
leader who is calling for more tax rises
what i am about
is about reducing taxes
getting our economy growing
getting investment getting new jobs for
people right across the country i'm
afraid to say the right honorable
gentleman doesn't understand aspiration
he doesn't understand the opportunity
he doesn't understand
that people want to keep more of it
their own money and that is what i will
deliver as prime minister
i will take a major action to help
people with their energy bills but also
secure our long-term energy supply i
will take immediate action to make sure
we have lower taxes and we grow the
economy and that way i will ensure we
have a positive future for our country
and we get britain moving
[Applause]